so after a freak life burial accident in
Moria it would seem that this channel
has now fused with the being once known
as josuke and as a result we also have a
new stand which is called subscribe and
wet in which we craft funky YouTube
subscribe buttons for all of you to
press for regular Georgia content
uploaded straight into your YouTube
feeds although I do apologize for the
wet path there that is both
unintentional and unfortunate hello and
welcome to the new world review your
source for everything anime and manga
and let's be real this is a very
bittersweet video because my three month
long journey with the madness that is
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure has come to an
end
and I am now ninety four chapters deep
into Jojo Leon which means I can
probably start making more Jojo content
knowing that nobody can possibly spoil
me now
haha so the lining but in any case we
are here to discuss my thoughts on part
eight which thus far I think can be
summed up with a big old and I should
say that this discussion is probably
going to be different to all of the
others because obviously we do not have
the full scope of Jojo Leon to assess
and even though it really feels like we
are gunning towards a conclusion now
there are still a ton of loose ends and
so much shrouded in mystery that you
know what that's probably a very good
place to start actually mystery so if
for whatever reason you're watching this
and you do not want Jojo Leon spoilers
this is your big big warning because
there really is not a lot you can say
about it without ruining something but
to begin Jojo Leon very much buries
itself a bit or worse in a string of
every lung gating mysteries the kick off
right from chapter one with the most
unique Jojo introduction thus far in
regards to josuke higashikata I mean
josuke higashikata I mean Joseph in the
Cujo
I mean yoshikawa Kira I mean yoshikawa
Kira I mean look just gay is one
glorious mess for being and I do very
much like just how alien he is to this
world which gives his character some
nice or rounded potential being able to
handle a spectrum of serious traumatic
moments as well as great pieces of
comedy he's certainly not as flat as
some previous protagonists had been and
to his current credit he also doesn't
really get pushed out of the spotlight
by the Joe Broz and dojo foes of the
series and I never really find myself
wanting more of him either as I have
with past JoJo's and I credit a lot of
that feeling to his existence as effused
being with no memories of this world
it's like I have no expectations
attached to him as a result and I'm free
to just enjoy whatever he ends up being
and just on that he's also a great
vehicle to get on board with in a
mystery genre because we see the series
primarily
through his perspective and discover
things generally at the same time that
he does which is also a nice and easy
way to empathize with and put ourselves
in Jos cashews nas for the overall genre
of mystery I think that Joe Joe Leon is
quite successful because I'm assuming
that we're through the bulk of it at
this point and it is continuing to
unravel into new question marks quite
consistently giving us the answer to one
mystery only to introduce another
immediately after and ordering and our
key should receive a lot of credit for
being able to pull something like that
off because it is not easy to keep an
audience invested in mystery it is a
true art form that's because in a lot of
cases it can lead to mystery fatigue
where you get sick of always receiving a
question as an answer but I'd say that
George Owen keeps me simultaneously
satisfied with what we're given as well
as starving for more I guess if I had
one criticism in regards to this sir it
would be that the antagonists a drip fed
into the story with no clear goal in
sight from a narrative perspective and
what they mean by that is that the large
majority of the series we seem to move
from group to group to group and none of
them really provide a resolution worthy
of spending a huge chunk of the series
dealing with them so the first group
would be the Hugo should cut the family
and we spend a lot of time exploring
them as antagonists but then things
settle down and we find ourselves having
made next to no progress okay and then
after that we get invested in the Tamaki
dama stuff only to see all of them
defeated with once again very minimal
progress and then a new cohort springs
up out of nowhere most of whom are dead
by now and it still kind of feels like
we haven't really gotten too far into
things and it also leaves a lingering
like when we get to these guys is yet
another group just going to spring up
until we do eventually finally hit the
final boss I mean probably not because
we do have some pretty well-defined
candidates for that role now but for a
lot of Joe Joe Leone it is tempting to
question the entire purpose of the
series and the absence of an overly
present bad guy is both a detractor in
this making the series feel like it
might lack a direction however it's also
a great benefit because not thinking
about an ultimate goal does allow us to
enjoy the series for what it is in every
chapter rather than always thinking
about moving forward and that was a very
big problem I had personally would start
us Crusaders
because I knew the Gulf from the
beginning Egypt dear Don that was it and
as fun as that series was most of the
stand users just felt like annoying
roadblocks in the way of the actual
substance of the series so I am kind of
enjoying not knowing the destination of
Joe Joe Leone and the same sort of
questioning plays not just into the
overall story but the characters as well
because thinking about it partake
contains very very few character
Who I am absolutely certain and I like
for the most part these guys were all
quite morally gray and have aspects of
great good coupled with great
selfishness something that was also very
apparent and steel ball run and I
spouted great praise for the idea that I
was never quite sure just how on board I
should have been with Johnny Joestar and
that feeling can be applied to pretty
much the entire cast of part eight there
are exceptions of course psyche also
Howe who seems to fall quite firmly into
an accepted social standard of morals
but then they were also more polarizing
characters like Wray who I do like I
think but he has undeniably dickish
qualities well even more norisse Kay who
starts out completely comfortable with
the idea of his daughter enslaving
josuke and even expresses that he wants
to kill him and like not in a comic way
either but then he becomes a fairly
solid trustworthy Ally figure but at the
same time I'm still like kind of wary of
him because he was such a prick in the
very beginning but he is certainly not
the king prick know that title certainly
belongs to Joshua and I'd like to thank
Joshua actually for being one of the
very few characters in Joe Joe Leone who
I have a very clear opinion of and it's
that I hate him to no end there is
literally nothing redeemable about this
character his design is garbage and his
personality is a garbage dump and really
the moment he lost me for good is when
he like tried to suck his mother's own
breasts but rest assured I thought he
was a piece of crap long before that and
I get that he's meant to be something of
a comic relief piece of crap and he does
certainly have his moments but those are
often preceded or followed by something
just so putrid ly off-putting that he
becomes a character that I actively want
much less of which is very rare in
Georgia because usually I complain about
wanting more of most characters and to
be fair I did lie when I said that there
was nothing redeemable about him because
his stand is actually pretty cool the
aptly-named nut King or not - King Cole
I guess but not King is so much more fun
to say and that presents some fun ideas
with it so quirky dismantling thing that
actually as per usual in these later
parts stands in general for Joe Joe
Leone have been quite fascinating to see
and read about I can't say it's been my
absolute favorite batch of stands
presented though because they have been
quite a few of them are I just went yeah
alright sure but some of my favorites
would be vitamin C because of how
amazing the art was we'll have the
fingerprints left on everything as well
as the masterful like melting style
effect that are key applied to the
characters affected by it
plus it was one of those situations that
comes up from time to time in Georgia
where the very idea of a stand gave me a
legitimate jolt of terror another great
one would be ozone baby which was a nice
air
of effect and that led to some very
well-done drama and action I can't say
I'm really sold on soft and wet though I
mean it gets used in some nice creative
ways and I'm glad it's more of a guest
bizarre power then something completely
Opie or geared towards attacking but
it's definitely not up there with my
favorites although I will say the art of
the bubbles is always quite well done
and they do like the star that adorns
all of them one of the coolest things
about Jojo Leon though is that like
steel will run it does not rely solely
on stand powers and there is an entire
faction of rock humans and in fact rock
animals that we get to explore as well
although not in as much depth as I'd
like but there is still time for that
because part eight is ongoing for now
I'm just glad that stands on everything
and we do have a more dynamic system of
power to play with and I've brought it
up enough times now but one of the
things I do appreciate most about Jojo
Leon is its direct connection with steel
bull run and when we got to hear the
tale of the tragedy of Johnny Joestar it
was pretty gut-wrenching but also
simultaneously kind of awesome because
it was just nice to see that character
again which I wasn't expecting because
Jojo leo makes a massive leap through
time all the way to the year 2011 and
I'll be honest when I saw Joe's case
designed not knowing anything about the
series I thought that we might be taking
things slow again in this part might
take place in World War one with josuke
in the Navy but no no no fairly modern
day or I guess it probably would have
been 100% Monday when it began
publication in any case what this does
is more or less give us a fairly
complete alternate universe Joestar
family tree which is very fun to find
the alternative characters we know and
love although I can't help but wonder
where things go from here our key has
kind of recreated the majority of his
history and there aren't a lot of open
slots for alternate characters at the
moment I mean actually there's no
alternate giorno or Jolene yet so I
guess either one of them could helm a
hopeful part 9 or I guess it doesn't
even have to stick to the alternate
universe door because if I've learned
nothing else during this journey it's
that you really should not try to
predict what sort of madness Archie is
going to come up with back to pod 8
though I do like one of the overarching
themes which has to do with Parenthood
and the parent-child relationship
there's a strong through line in George
only on exploring what makes a good or a
bad parent and even if such a concept is
that simple like there's a lot of
examples of good parents who do bad
things and commit sacrifices they deem
necessary to secure the future of their
children but our our key also plays with
parental neglect and regret a lot as
well like the one chapter that is burned
into my mind is way
young Joseph Umi was drowning at the
beach and his mother was just
legitimately struggling with the idea
should I save him or is this my ticket
out of this situation a tragic accident
on the beach
oh no and it's sickening but mostly
because it comes equipped with a tragic
degree of truth in that these are real
feelings that I'm sure many parents have
had even if it was the most fleeting of
thoughts and would never eventuate
because raising kids is not easy or at
least I'm assuming it's not easy I am
only the parent of a dog he's not easy
though he sheds a lot but this
exploration also goes the other way with
a lot of focus on what children are
willing to do to help their parents
which is Jose Kay's entire mission
actually to help the woman that he now
recognizes as a mother but this feeling
gets twisted as well in the form of
Tsurugi who is constantly struggling
with what is right and wrong and don't
think I've forgotten about that chapter
which started literally minutes before
the harvest where he was dragging Norris
case seemingly dead body and obviously
that could just be nice out of context
tease from Archy and this could be some
grand plan for our protagonist but at
the same time there is undeniable
potential for Joe Joe Leone to go super
dark and I'd actually like to see that
because it's done such a great job of
handling the genuine struggles of
humanity so far that why not go all the
way and plunge our characters into a
truly sickeningly human situation but
sad thing is that while we're not gonna
find out for a while
sad for me that is because most of you
have probably already come to terms with
monthly manga by this point but I am now
one of you I have no idea when the next
chapter comes out but I will be straight
on top of that as soon as I discover it
and if anyone's actually interested then
I can probably review it here in the
same manner that I review one piece
chapters on the ground line review but
to finish this as an overall impression
Joe Joe Leon has me very interested if
not just flat-out hooked I'm not going
to make statements about where I drank
it with the other parts because I do
have another video plan to do exactly
that but I really enjoyed it and I don't
think that there are a lot of criticisms
necessary in this alternate universe arc
you really seems to have his stuff
together in terms of characters ability
and story it's kind of incredible
actually
and very much why I would like a partner
and that pretty much does it for this
review of Joe Joe Leon if you enjoyed
this video in the content this channel
produced in general then please do
consider donating to the New World
review patreon because the support of
all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this charm possible
and if patreon is a quite your style
then please do leave this video like
share or subscribe because it also helps
support this channel and in cred
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time and please do head over to
my disco server where a wide array of
Shannon retakes place on a daily basis
and finally please do comment with your
thoughts on Jojo Leon this has been the
new world review and I'll see you next
time
you
[Music]